hello
yes my name is Backlund I nice to see
you here I have to admit when I said yes
to give his talk I didn't realize how
large so this conference would be but I
think it will be fine so ya feeling like
a fake yeah maybe yeah maybe first about
my background I'm a web developer and I
work for an Icelandic company called
colibri and we work and team up with
other companies to build digital
products websites and apps but i only
started there two months ago and before
that i have been an Android developer
for five years and so yeah I'm decided
not to talk about my two months
experience of JavaScript but I'm going
to talk about the imposter syndrome and
this talk is just more about feelings
and thoughts and the emotions which is
normally maybe not talked much about the
attack on for this but it was also
likely empathy talk yesterday which I
thought was great and miles they are
mentioned a impostor syndrome if you
noticed and so I'm going to tie into
this and the impostor syndrome is a term
that was coined up in the seventies by
two psychologists that we're doing
research on high-achieving women and it
refers to when a person feels like like
an imposter like a fake or a fraud in
their field and it's always afraid
though that everybody else is just going
to find out that they are not competent
and this is in spite of science external
signs of success like and they are just
dismissed as timing or luck or something
like that so I wanted to like ask you
here you know how many of you are
familiar with this feeling mice exactly
and yeah you are not alone that's normal
some study showed that sanity percent of
all people have like experience this at
some point in their time and two or five
successful people you know feel like
fake
most of the time and you will be glad to
hear this is really common with
successful and like high achieving
people and it's not gender exclusive but
it is more common with women and
specially learning like male-dominated
fields but you're also in a group with
people like Neil Gaiman Tina Fey Bill
Murray and Emma Watson we're all
expressed that they have experienced
important syndrome so that's not a bad
great to be a part of I'm come start out
just be telling you my story and then
later on I have some advices that have
helped me to overcome it and yeah i mean
i am a female in a male dominant
industry and i think like my intricate
this might have looked wrong from that i
studied computer science in the
university hun iceland and when i
started to study it I didn't really know
programming I don't like I'll just a
little bit in HTML and I accidentally
took one course in SQL in college but i
really liked math and computers so you
know i decided to try it out and and i
remember at the first like social events
in the school some guy came up to me and
asked me what what computer games do you
play and I was like oh my god [ __ ] I'm
never going to be a good programmer
because I don't play any computer games
but then I realized that you don't have
to play computer games to be a
programmer and you definitely are not
necessarily good program or even though
you play computer games it was a relief
and another thing I noticed when I was
in in the university that like it's
difference between guys and girls
because like I was one of very few girls
in my studies were just like I don't
know to Rihanna's baby and and I I
really have this urge to talk about my
feelings with
my girlfriends and I do that like all
the time and if I'm just rush to stuff
like that but the guys really don't do
that and it was so often like like I was
like a total stress and freaking out
because I didn't understand anything but
it was afraid to tell it tell it to the
guys because like they never expressed
it but then like I always like found out
later on that the most of them were just
as stressed as me and didn't like to
understand everything and some stuff
like that so you know I encourage you
guys if you feel like that system I talk
about your emotions and your feelings I
think it's definitely better and it's
normal I mean I can understand that he
feels like an imposter when you are
studying and I mean and it's common with
students to feel feel the imposter
syndrome because like you don't know
everything and you're constantly
learning and like I just had this
nagging fear that I was not good enough
programmer and expected it would just
you know go away after I graduated but
then it kind of didn't and I studied
Android programming the first time it
was taught here in Iceland 2009 to 10
and then i graduated in 2010 and i
started to work on Android and PHP if
you remember left programming limits but
mostly enter it and you know date
another android program on the sides and
then in 2012 i was approached by an
icelandic startup called plain vanilla
which does the trivia app called quiz 0
which is like i would have to say the
past trivia in the world and has gained
like worldwide success and they
approached me because like i was the
most experienced the most experienced
android programmers in Iceland which
might sound cool but i thought it was
terrifying because i did not feeling
like I was left experienced but I
accepted the job of course it was really
exciting and we were just six at a time
and the company grew up to 80 people in
two years and yeah games like really
worldwide huge success
and even after a couple of years and I
was a part of this whole process really
deep into the development and and
everything I you know I still was always
afraid that you know someday they would
find out that I did not know what I was
doing and somehow I always assumed that
everybody else knew what they were doing
which is maybe not correct so about two
years ago I had had a massive burnet at
my work and started to you know some
soul-searching I guess you can say and
then I came across his term the impostor
syndrome and there's in a reading it
black and white you know exactly the
same feelings that I had been
experiencing that that was just a huge
of the first big step in getting like
overcoming it realizing it was not just
you know me being like an insecure woman
but this was just like a Sherman can
happen to our and anyone so yeah that
was great but like van in the past two
years I've done some things I feel that
have helped me overcome the imposter
syndrome and I wanted to share those
advices with you yes how how to overcome
it first recognize your success if you
just you know sit down and write down
how how you came to the place you are
today like what decision did you make
like when did it say yes when it could I
said no and you know what problems have
you solved then projects you have done
and know what new things have you
learned and like I'll promise you you'll
realize that you have a big part in your
success and then recognize your
strengths and weaknesses and like Miles
said yesterday I mean we are you know
human and we are all the same but we
still have like a different you know
your strengths and weaknesses and and
that's fine I mean some people are
introverts while others are outspoken
and I
is better than the other they're just
you know both just you know a human
elements and and I don't know about you
but I sometimes tend to compare myself
with other people that have there's
different qualities then I am or to like
you know people that really excel in
what they're doing but unrealistic
comparison doesn't really doesn't really
help so if we would just focus on your
strengths and if you can approve on them
and then we also you know think about
your weaknesses and you know maybe
that's something you can overcome like
for me it took me a really long time to
accept that being a single mom as I am I
just don't have the same time and energy
as people that on the children to spent
in programming and work and all that and
that probably means that I won't gain as
much knowledge sent you know experience
as those folks and that's just fine I
have finally accepted that and I have
you know different qualities I think
fairly decent that giving talks and you
know I'm good to work with people and
you know that might be something that
other people lack and and another
weakness of mine i have i have found out
is that I I don't ask for help soon
enough so I like tentacle and just get
stuck in a deep rabbit hole which makes
me really frustrated and before I
finally asked for help with this of
course not good for anybody but i've
been i've been working right another
thing is pair programming when i was
first as the pair program I was
terrified I mean when you feel like a
fake how are you going to fake that when
another person is just watching watching
over your shoulder when you're
programming but then it turns out you
know I did much better than I thought I
would I mean still today I get a little
like stage fright when I'm asked to
program and like being a driver seat and
when I mean I think it's just practice
and
and getting the experience to pair
program with another person and see like
how they solve problems and go round I
mean that's really valuable and you will
definitely see that other people don't
know what they're doing all the time
either you know so that's really
valuable and I'm not saying to pair
program all the time I definitely think
there's a time and a place for it but
definitely do it you know every once in
a while that's really healthy I'm
getting feedback from somebody you trust
somebody that works with you and you
know do it in a formal setting I tend to
when people like compliments meters on a
casual basis you know I tend to just you
know not really registering it or just
saying like either just saying it or
something like that but having a like
formal feedback I have both done this at
plain vanilla where I used to work and
we also do it at colibri we're just both
persons you know come prepare to talk
about your weaknesses and strengths and
you know giving constructive feedback
and I at least discovered that i have
some qualities that i didn't realize i
had and you know that's really good to
hear from a person you trust and it
doesn't have to be your boss or anything
just you know a co-worker you or use the
work with and then ask for house it said
that the worst thing that can happen if
you ask for half this that's all buddy
says no and I mean of course that can
suck and you have to be prepared for
that but I feel like the worst thing
that happens when I asked for have it's
not necessarily together no but then I'm
just you know exposing that I don't know
something and but that's there something
you like have to overcome and you know
just realize that it's not senior to not
ask for half because you know you never
learn anything if you would never ask
anything and in the end it's not even
just about you it's about you know other
people as well and it's better for
everybody you know if you work in a team
with it just admit that it does know
something and you would get help instead
of you know banging your
had to a stone or something and related
to that is be vulnerable by that I mean
just you know don't be afraid to express
your thoughts and feelings they're
definitely as valid as everybody else's
and you know it don't have to be afraid
to be wrong everybody is wrong everyone
to my wife I mean precedence or wrong
all the time it's okay for you to be
wrong and even if you like sometimes
feel stupid if you say something that
does not mean that you were stupid and
everybody has that's every yeah every
now and then yeah we are just human and
humans are not perfect I gave gave his
talk as well at the dais meet up here in
Iceland a couple of weeks ago and I got
a lot of really good feedback format and
some of the feedback I got made me add
this slide into it was that like I'm
talking about you know showing respect
and no being vulnerable asking for half
and that kind of depends on that you
like trust your teammates and your
company and yeah it's been said to me
like that not all workplaces or like
that you know in some workplaces below
it's like frowned upon to show any
weakness of asking cash for something
you know and some people said it was
coming in ad agencies i don't know i
just heard that and but first of all if
you work in a workplace like that i
would just tell you to get the hell out
of there and go work somewhere where you
have feel good and but another thing
also i feel like actually having that
would you say yeah having that in the
workplace gives you like tools and
platforms to you know you're expected to
say that if you don't know something or
if you need help like in our daily
meetings you know you should say if if
you need help to something and you know
doing rattles going over what went wrong
and what you can do to improve on it so
i definitely think that's a good place
to start if you don't have it as well
and then like at cooley bri we have
taken it a bit further and i don't know
if you heard about Jim McCarthy's 11
protocols core protocols has anybody
heard about it okay okay is it
definitely google it i wasn't sure like
if people knew about it or not but Tim
McCarthy worked for Microsoft for many
many years and he was just really good
at you know building teams and he'll
expect that in two or three years just
researching how how was the best way to
work at a team and being good teammate
and you know so it seemed basically
works for the minimal amount of time but
maximum amount of output and that really
depends on that people feel they can be
himself and feel good working in a team
so he has like these 11 protocols I'm
not going to go through them all one of
them is you know ask for help one I
wanted to you know explain is check-ins
this is a thing you do either at the
start of a meeting or on a regular basis
like it Coldplay we do this just every
friday and then also in some meetings
and then you go the circle so everybody
shares their feelings and we have these
four feelings you you you go by that's
you know if you're mad glad sad or
afraid of something and it can't be you
know or something related to work or
just something personal at first you
kind of made me feel it's weird but you
know I actually start used to it really
fast and I love LA two minutes now and
it's just you know exposes that you know
maybe a co-worker you know has a sick
family member and that's why he has been
feeling you know Pat the whole week and
you realize oh man okay it's not because
he doesn't like me but it's because of
that I mean it's just one example and I
just definitely think
this builds you know trust in within a
team so yeah really recommend to advance
so are there any positives about the
imposter syndrome I mean yes there are
if you have it you you're very likely to
be successful you're likely to be a hard
worker you're probably like a
perfectionist so I mean it there are
positives there but if you don't like
what's out it can end in you know
undesirable stress and burnout and so I
don't think it's a desirable state to be
in in the long run but I mean you can
take some positives out of it definitely
yeah so does this connect to Josh gift
at all you might ask for me it does
going from like a senior android
position i was at plain vanilla and
going to like a junior front-end web
developer at colibri was it took a lot
of courage and i don't think i would
have done it if I still suffered
severely from the apartment syndrome
because I knew it would mean that I
would have to be totally honest about my
childhood skills wits or not that good
and I would have to be not afraid to ask
questions and yeah to just you know
being honest sand but you know yeah
having that Kurtz now it's the reason
why I'm here at the account today so
there is this josh with connection and I
mean and then I don't know if you can
completely overcame it I don't know I
don't feel I definitely have just you
know on wednesday i went to the reactor
workshop with brian hall which was by
the way really good and in the morning
he had like some examples we did and
then we had to do some exercise I'm i
started
so it looked really simple and I
couldn't get it to build and was like oh
my god there's always people there they
can see what I'm doing and you know my
brain just goes into oh my god I'm so
silly I'm so stupid i can do this and
you know it's totally not logical i know
that but you know sometimes you can't
control your brain but it just takes you
know a couple of minutes today for me to
get out of this state and realize you
know I'm just new at javascript it's
okay even if i don't know the syntax
completely and in the next exercise I
know I I know this now and I just asked
Matt my coworker to who was also there
to help me and just when you're insecure
about something and you have some
problem just you know saying it out loud
makes it so much smaller and easier even
though it can be hard but it really does
and now I can just you know laughs
laughs at this afterwards and meow so I
just really think you folks for coming
here and I would love to get the
conversation about this going because I
think it helps a lot just talking about
this so I'm going to be here if you want
to talk to me or my Twitter handle or
email so yeah definitely connect with me
if you want to talk about this more and
you